[Music]
google managed ssl certificates are
domain validation certificates that
google cloud obtains and manages for
your domains
these certificates support multiple host
names and they can be used with global
external https load balancers and ssl
proxy load balancers google
automatically renews google managed ssl
certificates after you create a
certificate you may observe that the
certificate is stuck in provisioning
status
in this video you will learn how to
troubleshoot and resolve common reasons
that may have caused a google managed
ssl certificate to remain in
provisioning status
to troubleshoot any issues with google
managed ssl certificates you need to
first check the status of the
certificate for this do the following
go to the load balancing page in google
cloud console in this example the load
balancer named gcp load balancer is
configured with the google managed ssl
certificate
click load balancing components view
switch to the certificates tab
and select the ssl certificate
the status for this certificate is
provisioning
there's a warning sign for the domain
status let's hover over it
it says failed not visible which
indicates that the certificate
provisioning hasn't completed for the
domain
to narrow down the reason for failed not
visible domain status do the following
check if your domain's dns record
resolves to the ip address of the google
cloud load balancer in a terminal
session run the command dig followed by
the domain name
in our example it would be dig
gcpclouddomain.com
dnsa and quad a records for the domain
must point to the load balancer's ip
address this output shows that the
domain is not resolving to the load
balancer's ip address
to resolve this issue update the a and
quad a records for the domain to point
to your load balancer's ip address see
this documentation for more details link
is added in the description box
be aware
newly updated dns a and quad a records
can take a significant amount of time to
be fully propagated sometimes
propagation across the internet takes up
to 72 hours worldwide although it
typically takes a few hours
the domain status continues to be failed
not visible until propagation is
completed
after updating the dns records rerun the
dick command
great the dns record for the domain is
now resolving successfully to the load
balancer's ip address
let's check the status of the ssl
certificate
the status is still showing provisioning
and the domain status is failed not
visible
next step is to check if the certificate
is attached to the load balancer target
proxy
check the value of in-use by in this
example it is none which indicates that
the certificate is not attached to the
load balancer
to resolve this issue update the load
balancer configuration
to update load balancer configuration do
the following click on the name of your
load balancer
edit the configuration of your load
balancer
click on front end configuration
choose the correct front end
go to the additional certificates
click add certificate
select your google manage certificate
from the drop-down list
in our example we will select gcp ssl
certificate
click on done followed by update
once we attach the google manage
certificate to the load balancer or
target proxy we see that the certificate
status now shows as active
congratulations we have successfully
resolved the issue with google managed
ssl certificates stuck in provisioning
status
for more information on how to
troubleshoot google managed ssl
certificates check out this
documentation
thanks for watching
[Music]
you